what are we life I think we're live so
today is welcome to the Friday review of
games I am E&E Lewis and I'm Daniel Pham
and today we're drinking red hopped over
which is a seasonal by new belgium there
you are Daniel thank you very much oh I
know your you got a chaser there yeah I
got a chaser the changement happens to
be the velvety peated cask yeah
seventeen-year-old which is yeah it's a
limited release actually they're doing
some sort of really heavily peated
whiskey and they they were switching
casks and they're like oh these pedic
casts would be nice for a finish on our
17-year it's quite that's actually quite
good idea all right well we're getting a
late start today because we're
incompetent yeah apparently it must have
been my fault I think I screwed
something up in the last show and I
admitted so um terrible that cradle is
not able to fix my home in the states in
time for the show so but if I fall well
I mean it's not an excuse it's a reason
but you were blinded by the laser beams
that shoot up from laredos eyes whenever
he gets mad about somebody misusing the
action bar you know we're in 150 square
foot space here and dodging those lasers
is pretty it's tough you need you really
need one of those Cyclops things either
that or you stop reviewing apps that are
rated less than force he was pretty
upset yeah alright so with us is
engineer right oh my are nice and hey
Daniel of course usually engineers are
shows but today he's with us because I
since he hasn't been writing Java code
for the last 20 years turns out he's the
only guy on her team that knows anything
about football yeah that's true so we
wouldn't be reviewing some games today
I haven't either right it's right the
only guy that knows the difference
between a round ball which is soccer and
real football which Americans play made
up pigskin uh yeah so that would mean no
one else knows anything about football
pretty much no yeah I was no idea I was
gonna be in the previous show too but I
don't know anything about you know
overflow menus or you know Jesse White
guidelines or ain't that kind of stuff
so plus it turned out that mostly we
were talking about soccer yeah and I
think cricket right that's what you call
Ozzy rules football is tricking
something like that and I steak right
yeah at an insect and horse the horse
yeah exactly does Mitt Romney play that
I maybe is that I don't know let's go so
somebody told me that I had an Erlangen
or hey it's time to talk about football
because NFL preseason is just getting
over with regular season is just about
to start it's almost labor day weekend
here in America and we are gonna play
some games about guys in armor and tight
tight pants smashing into one another
yes and bending over nope did that
partment oh you're right yeah when we
get setting us indeed okay so I so Dan's
been field testing all of these games
for us apparently not if not just as
part of his job but because he likes
them and we've got a kind of a nice
lineup today I think I think we do I
think we've got a pretty great life yeah
except for the ones that rato suggested
they all have different they're not
actually a football i think but alright
so let's get started yeah what do you
want to talk about first um so I'm gonna
go to you retro football oh hell yeah
you know actually I joke but the truth
is my absolute favorite game a long time
ago was super bowl sunday you ever play
that no no he say um I think it's before
your time as in probably before you were
conceived but um but it was a combo of
64 game and you you know you chose your
team and it had all of the teams from
the first super bowl all the way up
which by the way I didn't realize this
but well the foot super will actually
started fairly recently right in the 30s
or 40s or that's crazy
well I'm just saying I was reading up on
the history of football day and value
pretty old okay give that one away I was
just gonna say I apparently in 1905
there were 18 deaths and the what became
the NFL you're kidding no no you know
why because back then they played real
football okay real football anyway don't
anyway I so combo 64 game you could pick
any football team from any of the Super
Bowls that had ever played and and then
you pitted against either so you could
look like the you know the 71 dolphins
versus the you know 82 bears or
something I can't remember the exact
years but I and you'd call the plays so
you call the offensive play you call the
defensive play and then they'd run it
out and I love that yeah I think that's
why I like football is you know you've
got the play and you just kind of have
to see it work out see if you planned it
right I like the strategic aspect I know
a lot of people like the more arcadey
aspect that's not me I like to play
calling okay well you'll probably like a
couple of games that we're playing later
excellent went down yeah anyway that
absolutely nothing to do with anything
except that I saw the word retro and
football together and it took me down
memory lane it's a given your age yeah
can you pass me that the second depends
there I think I might need it now I'm
kind of excited why don't you take this
cocky say let English any hmm tell us
about retro futbol retro football um so
we're starting out with the the poorest
of all the titles that were suggested
just so we can build up some momentum
game and wouldn't start by looking at
the mega seeds new game options and
about so um I'm the kind of guy that
just skip straight to gambling isn't
everybody yeah right what I want to play
a game I don't get straight to the
internet work that's right options man
let's just keep options about I'll
figure out as I go so you game now the
first thing I want to mention is and
this is not a game play thing at all but
none of this text is anti aliased which
you can almost argue makes it look retro
except not the good kind of retro no
it's the crap kind of rich exactly
there's a big difference guys yeah make
sure you know where that line is right
there's like there's everybody dance now
and then there's sooo sooo sooo do okay
remember to make sure you're on the
right side of that line that's all I can
say alright so that it just sounds
terrible yeah exactly so I it was a
disease a lot of people had it in the
80s you to the right here you can choose
a quarter length and they have four
options and it's to me it's not really a
parent what the benefits are to changing
the quarter length for now oh there's a
game of the intro for a quick second
degree have we been muted this whole
time alright because there's some
rustling I wonder if you and Mike Daniel
is slid down so it's possible here oh
yeah did your Mike looks like in your
pants could you hear him it was coming
through pretty well considering you have
a really odd vocal arrangement you guys
want so I know you guys weren't supposed
to find out at night it's all done it to
next year yeah all right right the front
all right yeah it must be but yeah thank
you and as you can see it is duct tape
okay for those either wandering out
citroen is this is a professional yeah
of course of course yeah
so we just go with the 22 minute and 30
second quarter length want to go with
let's go with all-star difficulty and
we're going to go to start game by the
way while I while Daniel is doing this
if you see me typing over here it's
because we don't have a producer today
I'm handling the live stream if you have
any questions at all for us go ahead and
put them on the YouTube live stream
that's what I'm monitoring I don't have
enough attention to monitor anything
else so don't look at the G+ invitation
or the GDL page just right on the
YouTube page if you put down a comment
I'll see it and if you're lucky will
answer it yep so by the way quick shout
out to our buddy Daniel oh who has no
forgot yes Dan we have no producer do
you want to produce go for it jump right
on here Dan Galpin and everybody dan
koppen is actually away today he's at
pax with kokhim so yeah both of the
people that you saw last now they were
supposed to like call up and do a
hanging out with us and everything we
got a call it like 12 55 saying hey
we're doing that hanging out no Dan
we're not doing that eng out by
literally five if you called me at nude
we would have done the hangout all right
so anyway and also shout out to our
buddy Marcus thanks for joining us and
everybody else that's on the live stream
now let's go ahead and play some
football Wow alright it oh okay so I see
what kind of retro this is yeah it's the
crap kind of retro so that's like I said
we're building up to the great game is
starting out with you know a really poor
examples now this is great this is great
because this is like I remember these
things there you know you'd see him in
like shakeys pizza or something yeah and
it actually be all plastic plastic top
and they just have lights underneath
that would turn on and off Wow even when
I was a kid and they were brand new I
thought they sucked haha what is it's
it's a good recreation of that I mean if
you if you like stuff that sucked in the
80s I'm not really selling this mi no
you're not no so let this is dive right
into the game and just adorable
everything that you just said absolutely
on so let's uh let's take a look so
right away you can you can see that the
kick button is flashing so I
it wants me to kick if you haven't done
the tutorial which most of the time I
don't do you probably won't know what to
do but let's just press the button and
see what happens kick great so it looks
like the ball is traveling across the
field and this is the point where i
usually start button mashing because i
don't know what the heck is going on so
i'm just going to randomly touch the
screen and it looks like X's and O's are
flashing and at this point it'd be
really great to have some kind of
indicator to let you know what what to
do next now for those of us that do know
football you know you can look at the
scoreboard you can see its first down 10
yards to go but from a gameplay but
perspective it's not really clear like
what what commands you can you can push
to start the next play so well you see
here is like a pass button and a couple
of arrow keys for running but it doesn't
really say oh you can do one or the
other which is kind of what you're
supposed to do so let's just randomly
push the pass button and see what
happens nothing no feedback let's push
the run button great so now you started
to play and apparently now it's second
down and I was blocked and there's
there's really no feedback there's no
gap between starting to play and then
getting crushed by the defender who just
is just an X on the screen so it'd be
nice from you know when you start the
play till when you actually get crushed
to have some kind of indication that you
you can move up or down or dodge the
defender in some way or move the running
back you know I comes out we're supposed
to do yeah you're supposed to run just
press the button and run around I see
now it's third down oh my god now that's
certain now its port down when I yep now
it's four done so how'd it get to be
fourth down you i don't know like stop
or anything right there's absolutely no
feedback we're playing by the retro
football rules i see ya okay yeah
there's just now usual this isn't Aussie
Rules Football it's possible it's
possible I'm pretty sure that's not
football you want to want to have a much
more elliptical playing surface for that
elliptical plane server it's not flat
great right they play in a paddock not a
field I have no idea what it is I think
it's for you keep horses you haven't
spent much time in the country have you
done ah but I've only been out of the
country once I meant the country nothing
like you know not the city like you know
that stuff that's past Livermore and
Gilroy might as well be yeah today
pretty much yeah guys what might as well
be written fair enough alright guys
let's go ahead and take a look at at
another games I think we've plumbs the
depths of this yes no that's pretty much
it it's exactly I mean I really it does
definitely take me back yeah I only
complaint is it takes me back to the
part of my life before video games were
fine so absolutely sure if I can see it
appealing to some people not to me
personally but it is a well done
emulation of that anyway let's take a
look at something else alright so let's
go to UM that's actually good do and a
pelvic occur yes awesome great because
as we all know kicking is the most
important and exciting part of football
so but now kering that's a part of your
thing that's okay yeah and say yeah you
can see the cable from the tablet but
that's a that's fine I've dealt with
these people rather look at the cable in
your face not proper to yeah and my face
is big enough you can see it yeah it's
huge pretty much solo I've already gone
through some some of the game to you
know ranks and my rank right now is a
starting kicker so when you first start
the game you would normally start as
rookie and as you play through the
tutorial you your rank goes up based on
your score so I've already gone ahead
and unlock some of the additional stages
but let's go to go through the basic
skills and learn some kicking tips so
this is great you know while it's
loading yeah
to learn some kicking tips try to aim
for the scoreboard every time blah blah
blah and we get some 3d rendered
cheerleaders awesome whoa yeah let's not
pandering at all I'm definitely not
that's some of that animation was a
little disturbing a little bit but NFL
cheerleaders in real life are a little
bit disturbing so I think it's spot-on
and as you can see my player is wearing
the same number that i am number 52
Patrick Willis but in the game I've
named him something totally different
points to you guys out there who know
what thickness what thickness yeah it's
a it's a quip made by a NFL player
Asante Samuel you tweeted something
having to do with thickness okay no one
could figure out what it was and so now
it's become a really popular internet
name nice yes that decides it I'm so
glad we have you around Daniel or droid
would totally not be hip at all okay so
so apparently this is I'm just going to
turn the camera like this and then I'm
just gonna flick tell me that I'm not a
pro that was fraud that's a that's a
thousand points really I don't know I
thought it was like three
maybe nights of the whole is what is
constituted tutorial kind of basic
skills I just know Oh anyway so okay so
control the ball woods and fly it yet so
did pretty cool eh the ball was is that
actually part of an NFL game as a no so
this is actually into the realm of
fantasy like oh I wish I can control the
mall yeah you know like like Billy
Cundiff last year in the playoffs he
cost the ravens game missing that really
shanking left you know that that field
goal from 23 years only he had had this
/ Getty was able to control the ball on
in air he wouldn't have missed that the
goal post by you know like 50 million
miles now started all your ravens fans
out there it's okay I don't think we
have any Ravens fans out here now
probably not yeah tap the screen to
continue so now you can get extra points
for accuracy you can control the ball or
use the control scheme that we just
found the world oh no fail no good it's
friends again still fail apparently I'm
Tara woods game yeah I don't know man
yeah I'm sorry guys this is this is a
fail well look here let me try it maybe
it maybe it's not maybe it's not is a
swipe while you're in there yeah just
wipe yeah you're right unless order are
you supposed to actually touch the ball
the Whitney's actually got stronger than
yeah it's really strong you're right
okay alright so well anyway yeah that
looks like it's got some promise anyway
yeah so let's go to something fun game
though the graphics are really
impressive yeah I really like when I
really zoom in on the crowd and then you
realize that that totally doesn't work
at all that's what what yes so the back
button actually this a little bit
jarring you know yeah
way of doing the back button like before
we really figured out how to make games
good yeah they are really clear here if
you're gonna actually exit the game if
you go back to the main menu or what you
want oh I'm betting it's mr. Ellis oh
okay so yeah actually game right huh so
um what we'd really prefer is that you
just go back and then give the user a
way to go forward again instead of
trying to do a confirm and Android you
usually don't have to tear down and
rebuild a whole lot of stuff to move
from screen to screen so unless your
game is literally using all available
RAM on the system in which case you're
kind of screwed anyway you should be
able to go back to a menu screen like
this and give the user a way to say oh
no wait I wanted to continue my game and
get back into it without having to ask
for confirmation to move from screen to
screen even if this tape yeah the Google
glue duct tape fixes everything yeah
it's pretty amazing that one's lasted
it's like four weeks wonderful / Freddy
to go all right let's go to the next
game mode in the zone alright let's
check this out in the zone here we go
it's giving us a tip coffin corner it's
got a nice image of Lucas Oil Stadium
alright let's get chicken so in this
game mode is basically employing all
your basic skills that we learned in the
tutorial based on from before and it's
got a really great controls 40 as a fail
sorry let's try this every I mean every
now and then you get like a little gold
bar on either side of the field posts
and if you if you're if you're good
enough to hit that gold section you'll
score some additional points and it
doesn't happen very often with me as you
can see because i'm a terrible kicker by
the way we have a message from our
coworker Dan Galpin he says fams
football flicking fails frequently
thanks Dan thank you appreciate thanks a
lot man so you know I won't bore you
with it with this anymore that's that's
let's find another game mode that's a
little bit more interesting is no that's
pretty standard yeah i think you know we
got 15 minutes left oh why don't we move
on to some other insects yeah we can say
this is a this is some cool game play I
the and if you like flick games this is
pretty good example yep yeah it's got
all the licenses it's got a really nice
set of graphics got a few things wrong I
really really like to see the back
button handle differently because right
now it just looks a little amateurish
but everything else I think it ended you
know despite the fact that I don't think
it was actually created with this device
in mind it looks pretty good on the
tablet I agree totally agree the
graphics are sufficiently high
resolution to overcome any other short
Detroit comes yeah so actually going to
keep it in portrait mode one okay one
more flick game really quick from the
same developer if I can find it it is
NFL flick quarterback so this is
actually a nice little twist up click
games
we wait for that to load and as with the
last game I've also a cheaper rank of
starting QB and that's up from rookie so
let's go to the first let's go to the
first mode playmaker okay it's got the
same style you know same info info
between game loading I've obviously
chosen the same player with the same
name as last time this is great now in
this mode your goal is to pass the ball
as effectively as you can to the
receiver and using the same control
schemes as that the kicking game you
know you flick and you can control the
ball in midair left or right our
receivers kind of a douche yeah he is
all receivers are douche bags I thought
you knew that and nomads a fail and this
receiver you actually make some really
crazy movies yeah moves that not know
normal receiver in the NFL would be able
to make he must be on steroids cuz
nobody in the NFL is for sure nobody in
the NFL don't stare that was like duct
tape hands yep pretty amazing this looks
like a fun game yeah and this is this is
actually pretty cool so you know you can
score a lot of points yeah once you get
just you know look at how crisp those
graphics are all the in-game graphics or
just they've really done a good job of
adapting to different resolutions and
making the game look awesome yeah I'm
really enjoying this I can tell
so let's let's skip this gay bowed and
go to the next one that's that's pretty
much it and there's a couple additional
things you can do so if you if you take
a long time to pass the ball which I
wasn't doing it's possible that wanted
it the defenders is going to rush you
and you can dupe them but I think quick
fire mode here is going to have that
also oh cool so we'll quick far your
goal is to pass as many balls as
possible without running out of time and
every time you successfully complete a
pass you get additional time if you get
an interception you get points so we get
time to ducted you know the only thing
that I don't like about this game is all
the cheerleaders have the same uniform
what's with that because they all to you
for the same team america yes they cheer
for a meme America great not easy guys
haven't seen it hmm bonus points to
anyone who knows it lyrics to the song
yeah everybody needs lyrics to that song
so I've got 44 seconds and so let's
let's pretend I'm a really crappy player
and Oh sacked so I really like the
animations in between um you know
they've taken the time to animate the
player getting up dusting himself off
you know it yeah they've really taken a
lot of care yeah yeah so speaking of
animations I think that's a good segue
into our next game which is well it
would be NFL rivals and it's not and
I'll tell you why it's not NFL rivals
because even though NFL rivals is a
great game for some reason they have
never I they've never taken the Nexus
any of the Nexus something we've got off
of their blacklist so yeah I can't
install NFL rivals and I can't install
on I'm sorry on my galaxy nexus I can't
install it on my Nexus 7 kennice tall
and the transport 10 I was really really
just a woman you know when I went to go
and try and play the game you know I've
got a box of Nexus devices and none of
them were able to play them so yeah so
we're gonna review backbreaker instead
yeah let me just turn off the sound
oh that's not how i turn off the sound
okay get it right in no that's
interesting because I as you can see
it's muted but it is still playing music
isn't it yes okay so there's a problem
right there please fix that alright so
with this I can this is back breaker you
set my player I'll call him player she
should have made him thickness just like
the rest of the players yes said okay oh
look i put a i put a carriage return in
my players name and now he has no name
oh he's nameless exactly any plays for
the assassins and relax or the pioneers
I think these are aussie rules football
teams yeah definitely not American maybe
Canadian maybe the CFL may be listening
this game backbreaker yeah but it's this
it's basically the same as NFL rivals
and I'll tell you what's different is
NFL rivals actually has a licenses and
in addition the the friend challenge
mode allows you to gain points for your
favorite team which I thought was really
cool so if i put in like seattle
seahawks house my team right I then I
would um really your Seahawks fan I'm
from Seattle no oh come on oh really
yeah you don't think you should share
for the home team oh you can you cheer
for whatever team suits your fancy just
not the Seahawks it happens to you those
pansy-ass seahawks and you know that's
that's okay man they humiliated the
Raiders which I know is you look sir
yeah I know I don't I really don't like
the raiders and you know okay so yeah
I'm a Niners fan obviously i'm wearing
Niners jersey and my fiance is
from San Diego so she's a Chargers fan
and the chargers are huge rivals with
the raver Raiders there's no way I could
ever light the Raiders for two reasons I
understand yeah any time to get crushed
yeah by anyone else it makes me happy so
anyway um these so these football games
so again this is back breaker it's not
quite as advanced as NFL rivals but it's
the same basic idea where you're
basically just trying to run down the
field and there's guy trying to tackle
you you can do Kim you can spin you can
do all kinds of stuff and go back and
forth and if you get into the end zone
you know I guess you win um I really do
like this the action aspect of the game
cuz you know yeah yeah I mean for and of
course natural emotion you know their
their whole deal is they made the
morphine system that you know like the
star wars game to use the really
animation experts a lot of the animation
here is really amazing so we like the
game we just wish that NFL rivals was
available for a few more platforms
because we think it could be really cool
and I really really like the idea that
you know as you gain points in the game
you're gaining points for your team yes
so great I can we get that the back okay
so anyway um well obviously our audience
is hugely enthused by American football
because we've got a record 21 people
watching right now thanks for you guys
it's stuck around now just my ugly mug
yeah that's Daniel and co and like 19
people that are just saying they're
drinking beer so I think I've managed to
figure out a way to get Daniel to be
able to dial in via hangout so if it's
okay don't you bring him on yeah yeah
let's bring let's bring Daniel gulping
on that's right daniel galvan is coming
on and the numbers
danielle pen oh my god that's him oh
you're placing Ian space with Dan Galpin
space we can hear it in your dad right
now the monitor everything that go on
let's let's have a drink all the way
that sounds good yeah Cheers this is
another way yeah very happy for sure if
you would like us to do a beer episode
every week let us know in the comment
every week that that might be a little
much but ya know we'll just do a 10 to
15-minute beer review be really short
maybe we'll pre film it there you go
that was ideas we'll figure it out yeah
well wait for rado to sort out the Dan
Galpin situation when I came yeah so I'm
we can get a chance to play madden yet
but i think that's probably the next
tile we should we should spend the time
on sure you boss let's do some math
you've only got sounds awesome 10-15
minutes left yeah so Madden's kinda did
you know it's the go-to it's the big day
yeah I'm sure for anyone who is an NFL
fan or even a video game fan you played
some sort of so yeah some sort of Madame
before now the interesting thing about
that you know we're always telling
people make sure you can flick this the
thing that really confused me about it
was that you can flip and hit the arrow
yeah yeah actually the first time they
released it though you can only do one
or the other you can do both but yeah so
all right put up your your urine diners
fan no not the Cowboys please no that's
just that's just where it stopped that
was the it was at the slot machine
settled on no 99 are there we go alright
sounds good nothing but nothing but
Niners alright so this is a pretty good
great splash screen I really like oh
yeah i mean it's it's matan what keeps a
you know it's say they they had us
download 250
megs before we could even play the game
there yeah i'm just really solid on
earth alright so maybe this is one of
those games where i will explore some of
the additional menus before we actually
start playing okay so let's you know
let's check it out so let's go to game
modes and see so I really nice
interstitials here lots of good
animation you see the graphics are
really crisp love that only thing I
don't like is this big-ass prominent
back button down at the bottom here it's
a little bit why do I need paddle
there's a back button on the screen yeah
right before that you know why not just
use the system back button yeah just
it's kind of weird don't fix what isn't
broken so there's looks like there's
three different types of game modes
exhibition season and playoffs and if
you know anything about football you'll
know that there's real in the actual
gameplay and in football there's no real
difference between exhibition season and
playoffs is most of the same so it's not
really apparent to me what each of these
really does mm-hmm so let's just choose
one exhibition since we just finished
the preseason today or yesterday
actually let's just go with that all
right
not bad and it that was strange so we
did freeze for a few seconds there and
that was a bit unusual I didn't expect
that to happen that's all right yeah
it's got its ups and downs there Rams
and niners yeah okay now I got it I got
a little bit about the texel density on
this SF logo here I'm come on you guys
that's that's that's bad you guys can do
better look we see there's Dan Galpin on
the screen hey Dan Galpin on the screen
sup man hey hey what's up so on yeah and
he actually sports back over i was i was
talking comments in the other window can
you hear me yeah yeah totally so we head
back side Connor I've been walking
around and checking out all of the crazy
boots all the people wearing cosplay is
funny because I think hello might be the
only person here wearing a dress suit
actually isn't doing cosplay but I
wouldn't be surprised people walking
around asking her which character she is
and it's been it's been pretty awesome
here it's kind of the craziness you
expect override override packs I'm sure
all of our dedicated fans or are
actually here and that's why they're not
watching today either no dan I know is
it is it you being gone is it the
football thing is it just me I don't is
it my hair cut I don't know but yeah
what convinced you have to drink over
the show it's been really funny is
possible it is definitely possible
having out of nuts to drink but yeah we
can fix that yeah we're working on it
we're getting there and yeah we're
having this Red Hawk Tober you got to
try it yes yeah so what's the coolest
thing you saw back there for me tomorrow
so what's the coolest thing you've seen
a pack so far ah I'm actually going to
see a a true triple to your t-shirt in
the flesh o-town t-shirt weights are you
going to score some of those for us yeah
get me give me one miss you get
oh oh oh no oh no you do oh no there's
no purchasing enery owes me you tell him
that okay I'll let her know hmm cool
what else have you seen on to the show a
lot more than I haven't we're going to
do is take the video camera around try
to take some shots for you guys for next
week and hopefully you know come up with
kind of a state of the industry here at
pax that's great yeah we're going to do
a pax retrospective next week we'll be
looking at some of the games that Danny
co saw and do a little bit of the
walking around thing some of the on-air
stuff we're going to do some video
editing it's gonna be cool we're little
it really looking forward to it and
where y'at now it looks so peaceful and
calm yeah it looks nothing like Google
center so it basically me at about a
thousand people smoking nice yeah that's
awesome well say hi to all of them give
them our URL cuz God knows we need some
viewers yeah only 20 something them
today yeah I know man that's kind of sad
then a lot of sitcoms actually so I'm
gonna watching a good comedy threshold
here do you think we do better with a
laugh track drama I mean there's always
these always the question of whether or
not that technology is actually gonna
work that's true that's that's on
purpose I hope everyone everyone knows
that that the technology you know we
screwed up on purpose because otherwise
things would be you know too perfect and
that's right boy we wouldn't do this on
accident we're Google yeah we're not
with us android / radio nobody even
knows we're doing that yeah way this hot
100 square foot room you know in like
the corner like no lights it's it's
pretty carpet in here but it's awesome
so that's just great
you view of this office that I get from
the hangout is actually pretty cool
that's like the top of IANS head oh yeah
hey Dad nice yeah camera behind you so
that's kind of um oh that's true yeah
all right well cool well keep us posted
dad have fun at the convention don't
forget to come back in time to make your
salsa or whatever yeah we are we gonna
be too drunk to make it tonight we miss
you I fully understand know where I am
we're going to come prepared excellent
All Right see you tomorrow man take care
of we'll see you later care all right so
now we're back to the coin toss this is
this is my favorite part of every NFL
game the coin toss realizing it's the
moat no no it is pretty sweet though
isn't it looked but the coin is quite
quite quite detailed and that's a
great-looking coin that's a really thin
coin that's like a yeah it's like a two
dimensional coin that ice and that we
won't wait foot yes that coin breaks the
space-time continuum in multiple ways oh
look i can either defend or defend wait
oh I can yeah you can choose which side
is defended but since the wind is
straight up at 10 miles an hour it
really makes no difference they've
totally defend yeah what's your great
that's a good point right up we should
definitely defend I think I'm gonna get
hang it is NFL stuff yeah yeah good for
you see an aussie rules they don't have
defending it's not a thing it's this
attack attack attack pretty much yeah
it's actually pretty accurate yeah okay
okay and this is stuff i love the all
the play calling me too cuz God knows I
love good squib what I like to see
tutorial okay so they really put a lot
of thought into this game and you'd
expect that I mean it ca it's madden
this is one of their major franchises
you know I don't know if you were at e3
last year which remember they actually
had a spread across you know they're
like mad not every single screen known
to man no I was on III but I could
totally imagine them at
Madden on everything that they see
that's the thing you're supposed to say
oh yeah I was III you're right do you
remember that one time we got totally
drunk at that bar yeah I do yeah it was
a great great time yeah because we're in
down insiders but yeah oh yeah no I'm
just agreeing with you because I was so
drunk it on my for anything it's good
point all right so okay um I will say
though that when promised a tutorial I
was hoping for a tutorial I don't
consider this to be a tutorial I
consider this to be a man page with
pictures yes so everything in madden
should be a man page with pictures no
text right uh so yeah what the wait oh
I'm wonder oh I'm dragging the ball down
then up wonderful I guess great kickoff
that was pretty good right into the end
five yards deep good mi man David that
guy should of just how great is David
Akers right I don't know how great is
that Avengers he's pretty great be naked
so great yeah that's why as I was
telling him just the other day David
Akers you're not bad but my buddy Daniel
actually thinks you're great I think you
know seem better David Akers if you're
watching this cheers right ya know if
you're one of the 22 watching now which
I can only assume that is 22 now because
dan got back online yes hi dad alright
so yeah glad to have you guys here I'm
sure that you know the post ly bodies
don't huge not actually we were just to
know this is a good time to talk about
this so we were mentioning that we might
want to change the time of this because
we realized that actually this is
probably not something that people watch
it work so when we looked at our
audience statistics mostly people in
Europe who are watching us right before
they go to bed because it's basically
you know they need to shoot up and as
they're shoving the intravenous alcohol
needle into their veins it's either us
or the simpsons and they've already seen
all six hundred episodes of The Simpsons
but my point is I mean I have a lot
that's a little bit flattering not a lot
not a lot of yeah absolutely absolutely
yeah
yep so but yet not a lot of people in
the US watching us right now probably
because they have better things to do
like work yeah so because that's all
Americans do they work they watch
football and drink beer and eat
cheeseburgers that's right usually at
the same time but here's the thing so I
if you um we also know that we're a
little late for the European audience
and I don't even know what time is in
Australia you know as I'm concerned
they're on a different planet if you I
twenty five o'clock yeah there you go if
you have any ideas as to like a better
time for us to broadcast keep in mind
that it just needs to be late enough for
us to drink beer because otherwise we
can't speak at all I think I've proven
that adequately it's just about eight
o'clock in the morning tomorrow in
Sydney which is a terrible time to drink
beer eight o'clock in the morning that's
getting started it's it's twelve o'clock
somewhere in the world that's a good
point yeah what all right so anyway
point is I in the comments give us some
ideas on you know when we could get
going and Dan Oh dance mentions that
we're good substitutes for David
Hasselhoff bite your tongue dan we are
never going to be good substitutes for
David house in a league of its own yes
yes he's he's amazing I mean sure he
does eat cheeseburgers that's the only
any kids li xin nian Egan's drunken him
you know gets his videos posted on
YouTube when he doesn't want them to buy
his daughter I guess I guess he does
have a bar scene but that's that's it
doesn't diminish his star power anyway
looks uh what is this it's good back to
the game yeah yeah exactly uh yeah let's
let's just get all this double entendre
stuff out of the way and choose between
plays I'll see I've got man cover one
man covered today and blind aight man
right off so right off the bat I can
stay right right away that for a non NFL
point I'm fan or someone who's never
played that in before it's gonna be a
little bit confusing it's really
confusing now it does have a few like
lines and stuff so from a madden
perspective it's great because you get
all the options you want but from a
gaming perspective I think they could do
a better job of explaining a little bit
about what selections do what and this
is actually one of these so this game
released almost a year ago today and
that is one of the main responses that
we got when we released it we featured
it and people were telling us you know
two things first it's too confusing and
second I it's built for this device
tablet device on the phone it's really
hard yet really difficult and I actually
think a 7-inch tablet is pretty much the
device that I want to want to play this
on I agree i think a 7-inch will
probably the best form factor for this
this title so let's just choose one i'd
say okay let's play this game as if i
was a fourteen-year-old girl in Europe
who has no idea what football is and we
just select one and we just oh that
let's pick that one see the thing is I
had just assumed that we were okay my
mistake nice alright so you can't cover
two there instead of man coming to is
there a particular reason you going with
that option it was my short arms gonna
reach all the way over to the other side
of the tablet so you feel a little girl
long yes exactly exactly covered yes and
so I'll try harder next time sorry beta
please do yes so okay I'm reaching
reaching man cover one so what's nice is
that you all get to do is choose to play
and it is a for you and a lot of times a
madden does require some additional
interaction and since we're playing
defense there's not much you really have
to do other than choose a defensive play
and everything is gonna watch that cut
yeah you're like watching a movie okay
what now I think what's really
interesting is just technically speaking
the lighting on this is really cool and
they're doing soft shadows which is
awesome but what I think is really odd
about this and I don't know if it's it
for technical reasons or if it just sort
of slipped by but the shadows are
reversed in terms of contact like a real
shadow is darker near the feet and by
the time you get up to the head shadow
it's diffused enough that it's actually
quite a bit lighter in general the grass
is reflective Ian oh well that explains
the whole thing ya see I'm learning so
much about football that I never even
realized yeah we're just we're playing
football on extremely high albedo field
so wait does NFL not get played on
actual cross so yes I know yes there are
some fields like Candlestick Park in San
Francisco which get played on natural
grass and there are other fields which
are create injuries because they're
played on astroturf or other artificial
turfs and they they're terrible you know
what don't get all high and mighty with
me right oh I happen to know that that
in 1977 Aussie Rules Football started
and move away from horse turds in the
pasture and that has I'm sorry the
paddock and things have never been this
is a paddock its place really forces
okay great okay so you're absolutely
right it's a
controversy which to this day remains
unanswered I for one am outraged exactly
you're pro tern absolutely good good and
you and I can get along all right I'm
sure if I cared enough i would i would
also be outraged so I'm gonna keep
covering blitzing and doing my tight man
I type man don't really want to see a
tutorial because we've already concluded
that those are useless unless you know
how to read fumble great Niners defense
drj covers all right so this is our
first chance to actually place on the
pensive place I'm slightly disappointed
in the vintage so far how much more we
want to get quite possibly uh all right
yeah don't tell me that yeah show me how
to do this this is the interesting part
okay so since the Niners are terrible at
passing I'm going to try to find a
running back run play and we'll do that
one okay and once I go from blue downton
bung wishbone exactly so wish but let's
either wishbone or a shotgun all right
so it's really not there to me how to
actually start the play there's like
also did you find out so when they came
out I remember they were publicizing
this aday the game was supposed to have
this like bull time mode where you could
like stop the play and select your
receiver things like that so you would
have to have like super quick reflexes
yes you probably didn't really look into
that because you have super quick
reflexes but I thought it might open the
game up to people like me just because I
look like I have super fly super fast
reflexes doesn't mean I do you know
after a couple of these I can only
assume that it takes super fast reflexes
just to make your hair look like that no
it's actually always like this for those
of you that are wondering no you can't
have hair like me I wake up like this
every day you know we once we're into
barcelona and we didn't speak a word of
spanish and we had to find Daniel Pham
in a restaurant and our admin just walks
up to the maitre d and goes like this it
was like Oh see yes I yeah the guy asian
guy with the hair and the glasses yes
that's me
at the the user interface now on the
bottom right there appears to be no it's
not an action more rato it looks like
ginda symbols I'm not entirely sure I
want to lift me it's let's press it and
it doesn't do anything so actually there
we go so it tells you oh it's so you can
get on the offensive hot route that
would actually make a lot of sense yes
really does yeah doesn't it yes it's a
257 I'm gonna ask you guys to start
wrapping it up because I have to go and
phone screen someone at three o'clock
okay so let's ok let's that's really
okay all right we don't really have any
any time at all we played some madden we
talked to Dan we turn into 20 people
watched it's a good time hope to see the
rest of you out on the internet after
the show you know because we do have to
make sure that our ratings are higher
than ratos app clinic ratings yes
otherwise our boss is totally gonna shut
us down yes please not really anybody
all right it's been great to see you
guys I we will see you next week we have
not decided on the theme for next week
yet because we are incredibly lazy but
yes I have some ideas for games you
would like us to review please let us
know on our Google+ page it's
developer.android.com / + very easy to
remember that's a plus sign that's right
there exactly so I let us know what
you'd like to see on in fact we'll start
a little post going right after the show
let us know what you'd like to see us
review we'll also be taking a look at
dan's quest packs kokhim will be back
joining us next week and we'll also be
talking a little bit more about the
games that are being feature right now
and the process for that all that coming
next week until then we'll see you later
see ya later cheers